[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i try to get ryan
sitting down now it's it's
from now on that's what i want to do if
you're watching on the wide shot which i
hope you're watching if you listen
you can always watch but you're sitting
down i'm sitting down now
and i capture you sitting down because
it feels like an authentic
behind-the-scenes look at things
it feels good oh it looks like you're
looking down at me now
well get used to it oh god can we change
the uh i got a new chair
it's a really nice chair i'm colorblind
but i it's brown correct
yeah you could have [ __ ] with me right
now you could have been like
no dude it's green like whoa i got a
green chair
i went to this place uh i don't need to
tell you where i went but like they had
a bunch of little signs like just relax
the more i see just relax
and breathe the more i take a second to
do like
oh those little things those little
signs if you put little reminders around
the house like when i wake up the first
thing i see is
dude it could be worse it's on a little
chalkboard
i'm like hey you're alive like do
something
so just these little reminders in life
that we forget you know i try to go to
bed
and say my gratitude that i'm grateful
for it may sound hokey but it works for
me so
don't judge me uh i want to thank
everybody for listening i hope that
everybody had a happy freaking new year
happy new year ryan happy new year
well this has got to be better than the
last [ __ ] we made it
we're like a howard jones song things
can only get better
it's or it's like that counting crows
song late december
yeah that's a sad song it's real sad
maybe i should go to the beach again
remember again
i think i should na na
uh hey thanks for sticking with me um
this show means a great deal to me as
you know and we've got great guests
coming i really worked hard to get some
great guests here
i always do and uh i'm knocking on doors
i'm i'm
i'm really doing the groundwork here i'm
alone on this with getting guests as you
know
so uh if you don't know a guest and
you're like oh i'm here for jericho man
and that's it please please give it
another shot
even if you don't know a guest or you
look through the back catalog but uh
subscribe on the uh youtube it's so easy
you just go to inside of you on youtube
inside of you with michael rose's mom on
youtube and you just press subscribe you
can write a little review message me
i read them all and then you could go on
apple podcasts
and you could leave a review you just go
to apple podcast inside you with michael
rosenbaum an itunes store
and then you could write a little review
and that honestly what it does is it
bumps up those that have more reviews
because they're more uh what's the word
prevalent yeah it does something to the
algorithm because it makes them seem
more relevant and yeah yeah it has to do
with uh
numbers and uh algorithms it's all about
engaging engagement it really is so guys
if you will if you take 30 seconds in
right of you saying hey this sucks
well don't do that but you know you
could be like but it helps with yeah
this helps
i get so many emails guys from people i
just want to say thank you to all of you
i wish i could say every name but
you know saying hey your podcast helped
me really you know hearing your
episode with jennifer love hewitt or
hearing with doc shepard
whatever it is really helped my anxiety
and it was therapy for me and i really
loved the podcast and
that it really means a lot to me and i
read all your comments
and uh you know people who support the
show even more are on a thing called
patreon
and that's uh p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon.com
inside of you and to support the show
extra these people i never thought
people would do that but
they become family and they join patreon
and they support the show on the side
and
some get merch from me every four months
and uh
get to ask [ __ ] talking questions like
you'll hear uh today
with chris jericho and those are from
patrons and uh they get inside of me i
get to ask me questions this is just a
bunch of stuff different tiers
patreon.com inside of you um what are
the handles for
our podcast inside of you pod on twitter
at insiderviewpodcast on facebook and
instagram youtube.com inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
that is correct that is correct um
linkedin is there linkedin too
no linkedin that's old school isn't it
people still do that you know what it's
funny is i swear to god i got something
years ago and i looked at my email i go
what is linkedin
i didn't read it as length i go what's
linked my friend goes you're an idiot i
go yeah but what is
linkid it's linked in
link it in boom licking it in
link it in
uh sorry i don't know what's happening
uh
the band sunspin uh if you wanna hear
good music
go to uh our website will be up this
week sunspin.com
and we got all sorts of cool merch so
that's going to be coming up any day
this week now
um and also uh we do stages last
saturday
every month and it's pretty awesome we
do two shows 2 pm 6 p.m
january 30th is the next one we'll be
putting the site up to get tickets so
don't worry
we got great guests today chris jericho
um he talks about his wrestling career
how he
he really never got hurt he got hurt
once he did yeah and just like it's like
unbelievable we get thrown around like
that the [ __ ] beat out of you yeah and
just hurt once yeah we talk about so
many different things how we got the
title and he found out he's gonna get
the title
the day of the day of it's incredible
how fast like they figure out how to do
a match like a whole thing where they
throw
each other around and just beat the [ __ ]
out of each other and people get pissed
at him yeah people are like you know
it's it's just a really interesting
dynamic and if you don't know that
wrestling world he's an interesting guy
we met a long time ago and i'm glad he
came on the show
uh pretty fascinating and uh why don't
we just get inside of
chris jericho it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know what it is man
right away because you're just a stud
wrestler i feel like saying oh
[ __ ] yeah just to be cooler that's what
you should say just stud in general
and i'll say i'll i'll uh match that
[ __ ] yeah and raise it with
uh seriously my all-time favorite horror
movie right behind you right there the
thing
check that out kurt russell signed that
son of a bee oh that's great man
right that's the best that's my favorite
that's one of the best what's your
favorite scene in the thing
at the end let's just sit here a while
see what happens
oh yeah that's a great one you don't
know for you don't know right like the
way the thing wanted it planned was
they would just die in the snow and then
you know three months later when someone
comes to rescue them they take over the
entire world so
is that what's happening there we don't
know that's true open-ended man
i love it when they're sitting there
testing the blood yeah and that old
guy's like
i would one of you kindly get me the
[ __ ] out of here
that's right that's such a killer movie
man i love it how are you and where are
you
[ __ ] you man i'm in uh tampa florida you
know a couple wrestlers live in uh
wrestlers live in tampa right um yeah
yeah there's
there's a lot of guys that live in
florida because there's um
i don't even really know why i mean i
moved here almost
20 years ago from canada so
i don't know maybe tax reasons because i
don't think there's state tax here or
something or
there used to be um one of the like
developmental centers here but
i'm not really too sure why everyone
kind of migrated down to this area a lot
of canadians though a lot of the
canadian guys i like the canadians
i know you're you're not really you're
you're from winnipeg you're born in long
island though right
yeah yeah but i grew up in canada so i
consider myself canadian i lived there
for like 20 years about fact i think the
last time i saw you we played um yeah
chris
reeves super skate right exactly you
know i have a couple of ranger jerseys
up now i have messier and i have
ron duguay up in the room and your dad
played for the rangers
he did yes i was born in long island
oceanside long island i was born in
nassau community hospital but i grew up
in a small town in indiana like you
moved to canada
i lived in indiana from time i was eight
on okay yeah so
i was born in manhasset um also on the
island but yeah my dad played 67-77
so he was with the rangers from 70 to 75
i think he got traded so it was kind of
his glorious those five years
do you remember going to those games
were you uh were you a little boy like
were you were you born around yeah i was
only
like i said maybe not even five so like
i think probably three or four
but i remember literally sitting in
madison square garden
and i didn't like it because it was for
two reasons one it was too loud
it was too loud i remember i had this
little sweater that my grandmother had
knit for me and i was putting over my
head like this
and then the other one was i hated the
fact that whenever my dad
got the puck if he was skating down the
ice he wouldn't look up and wave at me
so it always made me mad he's trying to
be cool he's trying to be in the moment
in the game zone
and trying to score goals and stuff you
should be looking for me yeah but
it's funny that i just had my 30th year
in wrestling but my 25th
anniversary to the day was actually a
show in madison square garden
and i did a a a promo after the match
this time like
in my mind's eye it was like right up
there somewhere up in there is where i
used to sit when i was a little kid so
i kind of have that lineage of the
garden in my dna at this point
wow you know i was thinking about like
when we grow up you know kids usually
have like this idea i want to be a
doctor i want to be a
you know a fireman i want to be whatever
i remember
as a kid i didn't think anything other
than i don't think i'm gonna get through
eighth grade i don't think i'm bad i'm
not kidding i thought there's no way i'm
gonna live through high school i mean i
just
had this it wasn't like a death wish or
maybe it was it wasn't like i was
a suicidal kid i just felt like i'm not
gonna make it i'm not gonna
i didn't have aspirations of really
doing anything until
i guess late in high school i started to
think you know uh i don't know maybe i
i could act i don't know i honestly
thought i was gonna pump gas or work in
a grocery store
or you know because i worked in the
grocery store for three years and it
just seemed like the thing to do
and you know luck and all this other
[ __ ] happened after i
ended up going to college but for you
did you what were you thinking as a kid
because at 19 you're already going to
wrestling school so i assume when you
were
young you thought you were athletic you
were in a sports
how did it all happen man yeah like i
just uh when i was a kid i had this
mindset where i wanted to be um
i wanted to be a wrestler and i wanted
to be in a rock and roll band in fact i
remember this i remember
thinking but like literally kind of
deciding that very early on maybe
13 or 14 or something like that because
it just seemed like those were
because those were my two favorite
things in hockey but i wasn't very good
at hockey
uh and i just didn't like the team
element of hockey i like kind of the
personalities and and uh kind of the
spotlight and the characters
you know both in wrestling and in rock
and roll as well so those are that's
kind of like well
those seem like two things that would be
fun to do
and i never really understood whenever
you know someone would ask me especially
when i you know was 16 17 years old
telling that i'm going to go into
wrestling and people kind of laugh kind
of thing you'd be like
saying you wanted to be a mime or a
sword swallower in the circus is like
what
especially back then like 1990 it wasn't
as open as it is now where
you can go online and find out like oh
here's where you go to wrestling school
and
here's the secrets of the trade or
whatever it's very closed society how do
you do that
when you're you know 17 18 years old
growing up in the prairies of canada
so um but but i just kind of got those
those thoughts into my head at least it
gave me a direction
and a vision like i have three teenage
kids right now and
they might kind of know what they want
to do but not really
but for me i knew like this is what i'm
gonna do i just have to figure out how
the [ __ ] i'm gonna do it
but there's no other option so once i
kind of had that
that mindset and that direction at least
it gave me something to shoot for
uh and a goal to try and reach it is an
odd thing i remember look if i was in
high school and some guy goes i'm going
to be a wrestler
i think everybody would make fun of him
they'd laugh at him i'm going to be a
big actor in hollywood
yeah yeah rose bomb you're you know what
that and and the funny thing is like
you're laughing but i mean look
you went and did it so you might
understand like it was years later but
when i read uh
arnold schwarzenegger's book and he was
talking about how when he grew up in in
the little village in grotz austria or
whatever it was and he was telling
everybody that he was going to be
the greatest bodybuilder of all time and
the biggest movie star of all time
like what are you talking like a
bodybuilder movie star you live in gratz
like
wrestler rockstar like you live in
winnipeg how are you going to do that
like that's just stupid
so i always kind of got a laugh of why
does everybody care
so much about what i want to do worry
about your own [ __ ] and just kind of let
me do my thing i
got really thick skin early on because
of that
so even now here we are 30 years later
um when i come up with new ideas or
projects and things that i do people
don't laugh anymore because
once you've done it they're kind of like
well geez he's kind of dangerous now
but in my mind i still have to have this
attitude of like this
this can't happen you just gotta roll
with it stick with it and don't give up
uh because you can do it but it's never
easy but it's always attainable for the
most part
were you always fearless or like growing
up
you know first of all you were probably
a big kid right i look back and i see
some old videos like you
you had size to you right well not
really though like for now i do
but if you think about 1990 about 511
that was probably 190 pounds they had a
good
muscle shape to me but back in those
time
times wrestling was all about hulk hogan
and ultimate warrior and
you know those type of guys that were
you know andre the giant
the big john stud jake the snake you
know you steal these guys and they're
legit
six five six six six seven like that was
just the style
and a guy like bret hart was
considered a small guy he was regulated
to tag teams at that time
and meanwhile he's six foot one probably
two
thirty so i wasn't i wasn't big for the
time it was actually very small
for wrestling now i'm not because the
business changed over the years towards
smaller guys and more
exciting wrestling and sizes that matter
as much now but back then
you could be the drizzling shits but if
you were six foot eight 300 pounds with
you know
jacked up you would get a shot right
it's not like that anymore so
but that's when i realized when i first
got it started like i'll never be the
biggest guy
on the show but i can work on having the
biggest character the biggest
personality and the biggest charisma
and kind of stick with that which then
enabled me to get a foothold
and then when i first started traveling
overseas to japan and mexico
in the early 90s 92 93 94 that's the
first time where
i was working with other guys my size
were smaller than me and that's for size
really didn't mean anything you had to
be in shape but if you were
five foot eleven or six foot five or
five foot six it didn't make a
difference
so all of that kind of it was like it's
kind of the journey to get to this point
where you're
you're learning and seeing these
different styles
and these different ways of doing things
because you're able to do it around the
world and see that wrestling's not just
this
wrestling's is many things to many
people
just like acting is or music or stand-up
comedy or it's all about the talent that
you have
not so much what your look is because
you can always
fit into certain areas but do you have
the talent to be able to do that you
know were you a tough kid
were you in like in high school like
could you back it up i'm going to be a
wrestler
and people look at you and you're like
you say it go ahead say it
i think i think at that point for sure
but i remember like when i was
in junior high school there was there
was a bully like you see i'm not
bullied but you kind of bullied i guess
you'd say but
chuck fontaine was the bull he sit right
behind me in class and
hit me in the back of the head like
donkey punched me on it every time he
stabbed me with a pen i just
and you never knew what to do right but
then that's that could be one of the
reasons why i didn't get into
to lifting weights and and you know
experimenting with that because once you
put on a little bit of muscle
you're not as susceptible to having guy
and that was only a very short period of
time but
that never that never leaves you i still
remember that feeling of
somebody taking advantaging of you just
being an [ __ ] for no reason like
maybe that was one of the reasons why i
said well i'm gonna go lift some weights
you know charles atlas
the back of the comic book where they
kicked the sand in the kid's face and
then he went and worked out and
beat the guy up later but um
so yeah i guess i was a tougher nose guy
but just coming from my environment like
i have a reputation in wrestling forever
never getting injured
and that's the true story like never
once the only time i got injured i broke
my arm
um you can kind of see the scar there in
and i was out for seven weeks but that's
the only time i ever missed a match
from an injury in 2000 jesus
whatever it's been 722 matches whatever
the [ __ ] i've had
um i've never got hurt and i think a lot
of that is
just luck but also natural toughness
from growing up
literally in the streets of winnipeg you
want to say streets not from being a
gang but when you're a kid you've got
nothing to do
you want to get out of your house you
just go walk around
they just go walk around the streets and
minus 30 weather steal a ball of vodka
from
somebody's dad's liquor cabinet just
pass it back and forth
you're not wearing it's not wearing a
tube because that's not cool you don't
want to cover your hair because you've
been spending time on it
you know and then just walking walk to
mcdonald's
go inside grab a you know to [ __ ]
make world turn over because that's how
you can afford walk home
there's there's a saturday night for you
man so maybe that had a lot to do with
that we grew up kind of
you know durable hearty people maybe i
don't know
just it seemed like that background
definitely added to the to the physical
toughness and the mental toughness too
did you ever uh stand up to chuck
fontaine did you ever do anything did
you ever i never did if i saw him now
i'd probably run screaming in the
opposite direction but
um i've stood up to a lot of other much
crazier and bigger guys now at this
point in time
but never i don't think every i think i
think chuck is one of those guys he got
sent away
somewhere very early on he didn't make
it to high school i know that wherever
he went was not our high school he was
he was the
he was the the terror of junior high and
then when we got to high school
he was gone so if it was if he would
stay in high school i would have given
him a thing or two i would give him a
piece of my mind mike i'll tell you that
right
i'd say it's amazing when you do it's
very hard it's easier said than done to
stand up to people who pick on you and i
was a really small kid i was the
smallest kid in my high school
i remember this guy rich well um one
time he uh he knocked my books out of my
hands
um right and we're going i'm going into
health education it's called health
education you know you learned about the
penis and the virginia
and all that stuff and then i remember
the next day he walked by he was leaving
that class and he saw me it came over
again and did it again
right and i remember for the next for
that weekend i kept thinking i ran it
over my head what's gonna happen here's
what i'm gonna do
and i know that you're not going to hit
the sky you're not going to whatever and
i said you can't let this happen anymore
it's it's bothering you so much you got
to do something
right you can't report him you can't do
this you can't be you can't you just
gotta
so i remember he came up and he
and i held my books he knocked him and
one fell over and i just threw my books
down to the ground this big guy and i'm
going i don't know what happened but i
just said
hey [ __ ] you [ __ ] do that
again i'm punching you in the face and
you're bigger than me you can kick my
ass but i don't care i'm still gonna hit
you
don't [ __ ] do it again
and he didn't do it again he just looked
at him he looked at me like [ __ ] you
whatever he tried to play it cool but
he just left me alone i don't know what
it was maybe i just was like
i learned that you know even throughout
life you know a lot of those types of
guys
they don't want to get snapped up snap
and they don't want to confront anybody
and most of them have never really been
in a fight so if you do challenge them
they'd rather just go pick on some other
guy that's you know
just as small that's not gonna talk back
and that's always
the best way to do it i remember the one
time with my high school bully uh biff
tan and
i opened up the car door and i said hey
you get your damn hands off of her
that one worked too oh yeah hey biff
get your damn i had christmas
on the show he was a he was a cool one
he was he was a weird one
yeah oh yeah he's a good man he's not
telling you yeah what a unique person
i mean do you still have guys even to
this day uh or
during your career in a bar they see and
they're just go oh i'm gonna go say
something that's chris jericho and we'll
go do something
not anymore i mean that that that that
rarely ever happened because i'm i
i don't give up that vibe at all not
that guy and i don't
ever hang out with those types of guys
and that kid was a very small
like i said window of time so um
that that's rarely happened i mean a
couple times
but rarely and nowadays most people just
come to say hi
or right you know the best thing about
going to the bar now is is that you
never have to pay for a drink ever you
just walk in there
drink drink drink drink if you choose to
decide you know i had a party the other
day at my house i was like i better go
to the
grocery store and buy some vodka and
it's like all everybody bought me for
for president was vodka so i was like i
had seven bottles of vodka like well
don't have to worry about buying any
vodka for a while at least i'm easy to
buy for
yeah because that's the best thing you
know it's one of those things now it's
also different too is
it changes the vibe and you probably
have experiment uh experienced this
because
when was smallville popular 2000 2001 to
10.
great so you understand this you
understand this as much as i do
in 2001 if people
you know wanted to get a picture with
you they had to commit and have a camera
in their pocket or whatever as that
decade progressed now suddenly every
dude's got a [ __ ] camera right
so if you go anywhere hey man i could
get a picture
or i don't i don't know who you are but
my friend loves you
so anytime you right yeah that one that
one
yeah yeah i love the insult wrapped in a
i don't know you
yeah i don't know who you are i don't
care but my friend would like one
all right well so you're asking me do
you favor and insult me at the same time
yeah but so so my point is if you do go
out anywhere now you got to deal with
like this and then and you just gotta
say like man like i'm just here hanging
out with my friends
and and you know but then you come
across like a dick but it's hard because
as you know there's a snowball effect
where people do come over just take
pictures and then suddenly
oh jericho's at the bar and it [ __ ]
shows up here and somebody's
filming it for tmz that's you know i'd
rather just go
into like we do shows now it's just stay
in the dressing room stay on the bus
stay in the hotel
and that's the party area going out off
site
you know outside of the wire as our
military brothers say
i'm not as much up for that anymore
because it's just more of a hassle than
anything
and and i don't ever want to come across
as a dick but when i'm hanging out with
my friends i don't want to [ __ ] take
pictures
i want to listen to music have some
drinks have some fun and not worry about
somebody filming me which they'll do
that too
just like like i can literally see you
filming me do you ever say something do
you ever say come on man yeah i've done
it before too then that's too if i'm a
little bit loaded i'll just take the
phone and throw it and then you get a
whole
thing going to so it's better just to
stay in the safe zone
inside of you is brought to you by met
pro they've been talked about
uh on in the wall street journal they've
been talked about in
tedx sports illustrated men's health the
huffington
post met pro brings to life a whole new
way of thinking about health
fitness and weight loss and i think a
lot of people
just are kind of clueless they're lost
they don't know
what to do with their bodies they don't
know how to get better and if you had
this personalized coaching who
could tell you what to do and show you
the way
that's i need people to show me the way
i don't
reading instructions not good for me
i need ryan to explain it and show me
how he does
things folks do you want to improve your
health but you're not sure where to
start
with thousands of health strategies
available identifying which one works
for your body
is incredibly difficult according to met
pro the key to seeing results is to
master your metabolism
at metpro your metabolism isn't some
mystery it's a data point
armed with hard science metpro is your
health concierge delivering one-on-one
coaching
and personalized nutrition and fitness
regimens it's not just about weight loss
met pros coaches provide busy
professionals athletes
weekend warriors actors
and everyone in between with the support
and education they need to live a
healthier
life they've got these experts here to
help you if you're looking for a high
touch experience working with a
metabolic expert or if you want access
to the tools their industry leading
coaches use
visit metpro.co
inside to take their assessment and
speak with their team
to learn which option is best for you
and ryan listeners will also get up to
one month
free when they sign up you head to
metpro.co.com
met pro dot co slash inside
to take advantage of this opportunity
remember they talked about it in the
wall street journal tedx
sports illustrated it these guys are the
real deal visit
metpro.co inside
inside of you is brought to you by a
magic spoon uh this is a product that
sells itself
uh ryan when i was a kid i ate
crap like literally the cereals that i
had
i didn't realize in retrospect were so
bad for me but i just loved them
i can't really name the products because
you don't want to bat-mouth them but i
loved them when i was a kid because you
didn't care when you're a kid
who cares about carbs and sugars and all
these bad things that are inside right
not kids and then you get older adults
do well you get older and you're like uh
oh
your friend so-and-so's got diabetes or
as the other guy says diabetes
you're suffering from diabetes so it's
it's one of these things where you're
like okay do i continue to eat like crap
and not care about myself
and uh die early or do i make changes so
you know there's all sorts of things you
can do with your health exercise and
things like that
but imagine you could like eat cereals
from yesteryear
that you loved as a kid that tastes
similar in taste
but don't have the bad stuff that's
magic spoon so my friends
as i said before i i gave them each a
box
and they're like dude and that's
literally what they said
this tastes great it feels like youth
you guys got to try it
it's like you it feels like you i mean
look at this stuff
zero sugar 11 grams of protein only
three net grams of carbs in each serving
and now you can finally build your very
own custom variety box
you can choose from the best-selling
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry
flavors plus
brand new flavors including peanut
butter and cinnamon i haven't had the
peanut butter yet i'll be honest with
you but
i'm going to so what do you need to do
you need to go to magicspoon.com
iou that's magicspoon.com
iou grab a variety pack try it today
and be sure to use our promo code i owe
you a check out to save five
dollars off your order and the magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked come on that's
magicspoon.com
iou and use the promo code iou to save
five dollars off we thank magic spoon
for sponsoring
the podcast now you know there's that
movie uh
reservoir dogs where tim roth is the
undercover cop and he's looking in the
mirror and he's like
you're cool you're [ __ ] cool he's
talking himself talking himself into
something
now as you know actors performers
whatever we look in the mirror
you know here's your hair all right
you're a persona you're you're someone
who's like larger than life and
especially during the the heyday where
you're in the championships you're
you're like the biggest wrestler around
and do you did you
did you look in the mirror and kind of
like reenact what you're gonna
sort of like prepare what you're gonna
do like say i'm chris jericho and this
is like
some of the things just almost like
rehearse like writing lines of what
you're gonna say when
the microphones put your face are you
like preparing for that are you
impromptu or a combination here's the
arc for that and that's actually a great
question because
so when i started in wwe um
the first couple probably the first six
months or so i wrote all my own stuff
because that's just how it was there's a
famous
uh promo i did with the rock my it was
my big debut into wwe and
this big long i interrupted the rock and
it was a big thing in
1999 because he was super hot then too
and there was no rehearsal there was no
lines there was no
script nothing so then as the wwe
progressed they started getting into
they got they got a show on whatever the
network was fox whatever show
whatever network friends was on so when
they got their their major
network show smackdown we're going to go
head-to-head with friends
we're going to beat friends that's
vince's attitude right so to do that we
need
writers like to have on friends well it
doesn't work that way in wrestling
because friends are
if i'm you know a david schwimmer
playing ross i'm not david schwimmer i'm
ross
in wrestling it's almost like seinfeld
it's jerry seinfeld
playing a version of jerry seinfeld on
the show seinfeld but it's not really
him
but it is kind of him it's the same with
wrestling right chris jericho is a
character but it's also mostly me turned
up to the 10th degree
so i can't have somebody write something
go here's what you're going to say chris
that'd be like somebody writing my
answers for you uh
as we're doing this podcast you have to
have a mind of your own
and and so it it it became a real
sterile kind of like here's your script
and everyone would be standing there
with the scripts like a table read
except for we don't have six days of
shooting for this we've got
you know we're on in 60 minutes and it's
a live thing and there's you know
here's my line here's you know some of
us are not actors i
am but some aren't and so it just turns
into something completely unorganic
when i left wwe came to aew a couple
years ago which is our show now that we
do every week
on the tnt network owned by the family
that owns the jacksonville jaguars
we're doing great ratings we just
resigned with tnt for
10 gazillions schooling dollars whatever
one of the reasons why it works is
because
it was the first time in 18 years that
when i had a promo
there was no script it was just me like
what do you want me to say like whatever
you want to say it's like okay well now
you have to go back to where it used to
be and okay
okay jericho everyone says you're good
on the mic are you as good as you think
you are
are you as good as everybody else thinks
you are because now you got to get out
there and just say it off the table and
boom it's so easy
so our promos now are just off the top
of our head going through what we want
to say yes we have bullet points
a lot of it happens on the fly it's very
similar to
you know improv being an improv
performer you know if
you've worked at the groundlings or
something like when i worked at the
groundlings you follow each other's
leads you listen to what the crowd is
doing you go here
you know what the point that you're
trying to make is but it's never as
regimented as saying you
say this i say this learn your lines and
it makes it so much more organic
so much more fun and everybody's a
chance to really show their characters
which makes everybody more popular is
there something that you remember one of
your favorite things was impromptu or
you said it and you walked off going
that was genius i was awesome like i
really had it i said
you know you just felt like i mean
there's some nights where you're like
you know i just i wasn't into it or you
just you kind of just let go
honestly that happens like every night
like if it's when you get to not
being a jerk when you get to my level of
experience like you just go with the
flow i'm very good at being quick and
whether
i mean i remember we were in london one
time and they had these stupid glow
sticks
they were selling as merchandise for for
dx they were green
they were greens like green glow sticks
that you had a rave
you know you buy them and they were i
think they were 10 pounds
for a pair or something like that and i
was in the ring and um
somehow i don't know i was talking i was
cutting i was a bad guy so you typical
promo english people have bad teeth
third of the house
it was a non-televised show and as i was
in there talking this thing comes by and
it's a glow stick and hit me right in
the eye
and i was like [ __ ] and then i
was like okay
you want to throw a glow stick come on
who's going to hit me throw a glow stick
i dare you throw a glow stick throw a
glossy
dude there you can see on youtube there
was like a blizzard of glow sticks
like a hundred glow sticks coming down
and i felt like i could like
like a jedi like i could i was like i
could close my eyes and hit
but it was just this night of of this
rain down of glow sticks because of what
happened on the fly
but i'm thinking afterwards i got in
trouble whatever but i was laughing like
these people just paid 10 bucks a stick
and there's like 150 that's
they just they're literally taking their
10 bucks and they're so mad that they're
throwing
glow sticks at me and i was just like
that's the true embracing of the moment
we did not
plan to have a glow stick riot i didn't
even
know there was glow sticks there until i
got hit the face with one so you could
just ignore it
or take advantage of it now i've got
even more people booing and yelling
because
not only throwing objects at me but then
they realize we just [ __ ] wasted 10
bucks
10 10 pounds a stick so they got even
more angry so
just little things like that where you
take advantage of the exact is living in
the moment
and that's another problem like if you
have a script and something happens like
that
if it's pounded in your head to never
deviate from this script you lose all
those
little moments that make things real
yeah if you don't really have a script
you can go with the flow if somebody
says
a you can say b if someone says you know
you can go with the children where you
want to go
you like that that's the way you like to
work i thrive off it i mean you know
you say you never got hurt except for
you broke your arm one time
yes it's baffling because you know now
we know
in the 80s you know you i never thought
things were kind of planned out and this
and that
and even when they're planned out you're
dealing with huge
wrestlers and strengthened and slam
anybody doesn't think
wrestlers get hurt like feel pain
getting slammed and flips your bodies
take a beating i mean
anybody's seen the movie the wrestler by
the way was that uh pretty accurate in a
lot of ways
yeah i i know a lot of guys like that
yeah there's um
you know the guys that kind of worked
the way up and then
worked their way down and so yeah that
was a very
if anybody's watching this has seen the
rest it's very true to form and there's
guys out there like that that did
headline madison square garden that now
have to go to the
you know shitty little signings you know
the guy with a colostomy bag or whatever
it was
like there was a time when i was at
those signings and then you're like holy
smokes
i don't ever want to do this nothing
against the guys that do that but
you do see that you see it everything
you see in acting too man
oh yeah you know there's always guys
like he was the big star of the biggest
tv show in the world and now he's
working at starbucks or whatever i mean
it happens it happens to life
but i just wanted to make sure it never
happened to me you know yeah you know
when you're but when you're for instance
when you beat
stone cold steve austin in the rock
right on the same night
yes how long do you guys have to prepare
these matches of what you're gonna do to
each other
how long do you have i mean i know that
a lot of times when it's a
match it's the night of i'm going to do
this to you then you're going to do this
then i'm going to do this
i mean how does how did that happen was
there more preparation did you have to
build up for that
oh you'll love this one so i found out
that i was going to become the
undisputed champion
um by beating
the rock and steve austin was the rock
first steve austin second in the same
night which
first time ever understood champion is a
big thing you would think okay you
probably knew about this months ahead
you're planning for it the shows are
written and scripted to to build
that point uh no not true i found out
about it that afternoon we were in san
diego and i was at catering
and vince mcmahon was there uh with the
undertaker
and they were talking where vince knew i
could hear him but they weren't talking
to me
and he said hey take her you know you
know the business is going down the
toilet
how vince we're putting the title on
jericho
blah and that's how i found out i was
becoming industry
hang on a second hang on he knew you
were listening
yes he did it on purpose he was joking
with you
because yeah so and and what did you
what was your reaction if you could
remember
the the feeling you had well i mean when
at that point i've been in the business
for over 10 years so you know how this
business works like
nothing is ever set in stone until you
know it's like being in a movie
if you have a great scene in the movie i
don't know what's like for you
or you know even tv whatever i'm always
really nervous
when i watch back the scene i just did
the last kevin smith movie json bob
reboot
and we had this wicked scene but she
never know what's he gonna use and
i know he likes to film more than than
necessarily just in case
and i'm watching and the scene is great
but when i first saw it i was so
disappointed because a bunch of the cool
stuff got edited out like
i'm always so nervous oh no the editor
got out now right so
it's kind of the same in wrestling you
never know what's going to happen until
it happens and things can change and
so i just took it in stride like my wife
was like why didn't you invite me you
should have told me
i didn't know i didn't know until like
two hours before the show how did you
not know
because that's just how the business is
well well how long do you talk to the
you have to go to the rock and talk to
them all right this is what we're going
to do
yeah we could put it together we had
great chemistry so we could put together
a match
half an hour it wouldn't take long and
maybe not even that long like it was
just
some guys are very like now in wrestling
i have another reputation of like
if you have a match with jericho it's
really easy to put together
some guys will sit there for six hours
and put [ __ ] together not me dude
20 minutes we got it we're done and then
we think about it for a bit come back
and
maybe put some other stuff and change a
few things but there's no reason
to be there for six hours there's
nothing you can think of in six hours
that you can't think of in 20 minutes if
you have a little bit of preparation in
your head about okay maybe this would
work if that would work let's try this
let's try that
boom boom boom okay let's take an hour
come back
let's change this let's add this let's
change that and maybe if we change
something in the ring during the match
that's fine too but
it should never take hours and hours and
hours to put something together how do
you do that because i never
see people like talking to you
whispering like i want to do this right
now do you whisper to them yeah magic
magic magic tricks like what do you do
like when he's got you in the headlight
going all right you're going to throw me
upside down now does that
communicate too and a lot of times you
know at this level all of us are pros
and have the experience to do things and
sometimes it's just one word
a high spot or whatever high spot is a
combination of moves that you might
have or whatever um so yeah so i mean
it's like being a a high-level jazz
musician
when you see those guys get together
they're just jamming they're following
the changes and watching each other and
they go off right
so that's like you know watching the
grateful dead or fish or any creatures
yeah yeah he just watched they know
where to go like okay we're gonna do
this
we have an idea because we're all pros
and then when they're ready to go the
next one
the guitar player look at the drummer
and be like okay let's change the name
yeah
you know what's funny is i had this band
we're not in the band anymore we're
friends but we had a band for a little
while
left on laurel and uh they're like
always getting really high and we're
like let's [ __ ] just jam on stage for
half an hour i go
no like what do you mean i'm like
because when i'm playing a chord
you don't know what i'm playing nobody
knows what the [ __ ] i'm doing except rob
who's been playing his guitar his whole
life this is gonna be
terrible unless you guys want to play a
for an hour
there's those guys that think they can
do that you have to be pro enough to
know that you got to be pro to be able
to do that so there's nothing like it's
like i bring up improv comedy and
there's nothing better than great improv
comedy
and there's nothing worse than bad
improv comedy
and it's the same with jamming on stage
it's the same with
a wrestling match like when you have
guys in that the best of their field
it's like the greatest and these guys
that don't really know what they're
doing
right you can see the you know the
proverbial boom mics in the shot
inside of you is brought to you by
petsmart
my daughter if you could hear him
whining in the background if you listen
really closely
during this whole pandemic he's been
with me non-stop and i think he really
loves having me around
which uh i love having him around he's
getting older and it's really difficult
and i know that
unfortunately the end is a lot closer
than the beginning
you know what i mean yeah it's just uh
it's it's rough but having my dog here
with me during this pandemic has been
pretty amazing and he's you know his
hearing is going and
sometimes you know you're it's just it's
a lot and i'm glad i get to spend time
with him during this pandemic and it's
good to be loved and dogs love us
unconditionally and don't you forget it
and petsmart has really
helped me during this pandemic from the
beginning of the pandemic petsmart has
been an essential
retailer making sure you can get
everything your pet needs right when you
need it at
over 600 convenient locations
and they leave the pack with safe and
easy ways to shop
that's what you want in petsmart stores
cleaning disinfecting protocols follow
cdc recommendations
stores and grooming salons offer digital
check-in
curbside drop off and pick up and
contactless payment
petsmart has same free day delivery
powered by doordash
through january 31st curbside drop-off
and pickup services for stores and
grooming salons
if you're interested in contactless
shopping just order online at
petsmart.com
or on the petsmart app and enjoy easy
curbside pickup or
free same day delivery powered by
doordash
through january 31st 2021
so you can get everything your pet needs
right to your door and
right when you need it check out
petsmart.com
for more details inside of you is
brought to you by
someone you all know and that is geico
uh
most people have geico for insurance and
uh you rant ryan we've talked about it
it's a pain in the behind when you have
uh well i'll have a house insurance i'll
have car insurance here at this other
place and
what if you could do them all at one
place that'd be great well you can
ryan what you can what with geico's
bundling policies geico makes it easy to
bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along
with your auto policy and it's a good
thing too because you already have so
much to do around your home
go to geico for god's sakes geico.com
get a quote see how much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com inside of you is
brought to you by
echelon echelon i love echelon
i have a rower downstairs i have a bike
i have a mirror you know why
because i don't leave the house and i
can stay in shape doing it
i sit there and i row i rose and bomb
you can see me rowing right there i love
riding the bike
i don't have to hurt my back when i'm
running outside i get in front of the
mirror i box with different people
teaching me how to box and doing these
like 30 minute courses or an hour course
it's so
fun they have stretching the mirror is
incredible everything's really
incredible with echelon and i'm so glad
they've been a sponsor because
they've gotten me off my arse and uh i
picked it up a little bit i picked it up
echelon
echelon offers the next generation of
connected fitness bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines and
their echelon stride
smart treadmill and they've got the new
x75 connected bike there's so many
affordable choices
when it comes to getting in shape or
staying in shape nothing feels as good
as that feeling of accomplishment of
hitting your fitness goals
and feeling great about yourself these
things are affordable too way more
affordable than those other guys
i'm telling you trust me i like to get a
deal i like
deals their world-class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand studio level classes
always available when you need them and
unlike their competitors
echelon like i said is affordable for
everyone and one membership lets up to
five family members all work out
at the same time and right now you can
try echelon fitness equipment at home
for 30 days
go to echelonfit.com inside of you
that's
e c h e l o n
fit dot com slash inside of you
echelon fit.com slash inside of you
tell my good friends at echelon i sent
you
and they'll know it when you type in
inside of you
but back to the uh injury this is where
the whole point comes in
what if you're wrestling somebody and
you know what you're doing but they
don't do the right thing how how have
you not gotten hurt knock on wood in 30
years except for a broken arm
because look you say hi up or whatever
the hell you say and the guy gives
doesn't do exactly right or doesn't hear
you right or something
that's ha that has to have happened yeah
that happens sometimes
more than more than anything it just
kind of leads to an awkward moment where
you kind of just
bump into each other or you know it's
very very rare that it ends in injury i
mean sometimes you can get a punch to
the face or kick to the head and that
happens
that's just the way that's the way it
goes i mean but most the time
if there's a mistake in the ring it's
just because somebody didn't quite
understand or didn't hear something and
you might just kind of
bump into each other or miss something
or whatever it may be it's but you know
that's another thing too but russ said
the wrestling will get
dragged over the coals for something
like that when it happens but i watched
you know tampa bay bucks last night
against the freaking
times giants or whatever and it's like
you know sometimes the quarterback will
throw a ball and the guy goes this way
instead of that way and it just goes
like what the [ __ ] happened there like
that was a total
screw up right wrestling that happens
like oh it's a botch
he screwed up in baseball it's called an
error and football is called a bad throw
in wrestling it's like
crucifixion you know because wrestling
is neither fish nor foul
it's not a complete sport it's not a
complete show it's a combination of the
two
so it almost gets judged by different
rules because of that so when there's a
mistake
in wrestling it's much more by by
wrestling fans
much more uh focused on than when you
see a mistake
in right actual sports yeah but so if
like for instance
are there wrestlers out there you
included if you get smacked in the face
you're not supposed to
[ __ ] well yeah of course i mean
that happens too
obviously we're all on the same page
there were there were times back in the
early days where guys would want to go
in there and
you know take advantage especially like
in in other countries if you were a
foreign guy
coming to work in japan maybe the
japanese guy that's there every
every week every month is angry that
you're there to steal his spot
you might want to give you a couple
shots to face but you just give a few
back
and he goes back to the bully rule like
he said nobody wants to take a punch to
the head
you know so they'll just kind of back
off but i mean you do
you do get errant hits it just happens
it's the way it is
it's it's not a big deal i mean if it
happens two or three times in a match
then you might start you know sending a
few messages back but
right a punch to the face or kick to the
head or whatever it may be it happens
so you never went to someone's room
after the show and go dude what the [ __ ]
was that about
yeah no that's rare that doesn't have
you have you heard about that someone
comes in the rest
dressed like i said that's old school
stuff for guys to get in fights after
for us at this level there's no time for
that [ __ ] we're working on national tv
right you know with a million dollar
company tens of million dollar company
whatever you might say
there's no room for for that bush league
kind of stuff so we're all pros
were you always in high school wanting
to play music
were you always into music as well and
thought you know because you were yeah i
was i was way more into music than i
ever was in wrestling as far as knowing
like the the history and the trivia and
all that sort of stuff like i
i can talk music to the cows come home
wrestling trivia is a little bit
different because i'm not
quite as like i don't remember a and b
but i'll tell you you know
who the second guitar player was in the
first iron maiden record and you know
how many songs he wrote on who's the
bass player for quiet riot
uh what rudy sarso's my buddy
nicely he's the nicest guy in the world
he would tell stories how he never
really drank and
you know he'd be around all the big guys
and you know they'd feel uncomfortable
so he'd he'd have a drink but he'd just
sit there and sip it or
you know that was an old school
wrestling thing too even if you didn't
drink always have
always have one in your hand that way
everyone trusts you you can't hang out
with the boys and not have a drink
because they
think they're some kind of a spy or
something you know but yeah so yeah i
was always super into music man i still
am to this day and that's what like
with talk is jericho with my podcast
when it was first kind of pitched to me
i'm like it's great but
i'm not doing a wrestling show we'll say
well you gotta like i'll do some
wrestling but
that would drive me crazy it has to be a
combination of all the things that i'm
into which is acting music everything
yeah everything you know we do
paranormal and all that sort of stuff
dude i like all this [ __ ]
paranormal come on i yeah i just was
watching the image of a horror and
trying to tell my friends
i did this movie with wes craven and he
was like you know it's all [ __ ] the
emily valhargo no no no
the guy killed his family and then the
lutz family moves in
and then within a month they have to get
the hell out they left everything in the
house they had no money and they went to
the other side of the country you're
telling me
that something didn't happen in the
house and then and i just these
conversations go on oh yeah so oh yeah
dude i i actually we did a signing in
vegas with with my band fozzie and
i might be getting the kid's name wrong
but i think it's ronald
ronald lutz ronald defeo defeo
was the one who killed his family in the
original house and then the family that
moved in with the lutz's george lutz
yeah so one of the lut's kids i can't
remember what his name was oh yeah
michael no nicole maybe maybe i don't
remember you grew up in the house and
showed up at the size of hey man my name
is
michael lutz and my family is the anime
vujar i was like what like
tell me some stories man you know i had
also andrea perron whose family was the
family in the conjuring
i went to her house in winter haven
florida to do a podcast
and she's like oh yeah this house is
haunted too it's not the house it's me
and i'm like oh my gosh i'm just going
to sit over here i don't want anything
off of me and her weird dad the guy
that's in the movie played by
uh patrick wilson i think his name right
patrick wilson yep so now he's older
obviously because andrea's probably 50
or 60s her dad's
you know 70 80. and when she started
talk he was sitting in the kitchen we
were kind of in the living room
just sitting the whole time kind of
staring and when she started talking
about stuff that he didn't like
he'd start banging pots and pans
together and like
opening the fridge and like
causing all these noises and i was like
like he's obviously not happy
so he's showing his displeasure by
making kitchen noises
it was just creepy like i like i like
that [ __ ] and people
appreciate that about me as well so it's
fun to kind of have all these different
interests and ideas and things that you
want to talk about dude have me on your
show on jericho i would love to just
i'd love to that's one of the reasons
why we're doing this is to do the the
uh reciprocity dude location i mean i'd
lo i'd talk to you about
you know uh my guest recently was uh
bruce campbell he's come on the show a
couple of times and
i'm just a big fright knight fan and i
just love her so
yeah i could talk about harlow i just
did uh um
two things i just had for halloween the
top 10 horror movies of all time which i
debated with a bunch of different people
um which was great and then i also just
did the documentary in search of
darkness 2
which is completely based on what your
hat says i love 80s horror
so that was killer as well to kind of
host that and kind of
all of the seller dwellers and you know
973 evil and amityville horror 2
and like you name it we have it on there
it's actually pretty cool
what's your favorite horror movie of all
time on don't say it yet
like i said the thing the thing the
thing is number one yeah what's number
two
probably halloween the john carpenter
one two punch really you wouldn't put
the shining or
alien or or the exorcist or the omen
before that
um i love the omen and i love omen two
those are both of my top ten um i
actually did a watch along with kevin
smith
of the omen two because we're both
obsessed with that movie because when we
first saw it we were the same age as
well you two you're the same age
as as i am almost yep like damien was 12
and like i was like i'm 12. like this is
crazy like what if i knew this guy and
like
would i want to be friends with him or
not because he goes to the prom and all
the chicks are hanging out with them and
he beats up the high school bully and
like i might want to hang out with the
antichrist if i knew him he feels like
he knows how to party
i don't know what it is about horror i
think because my mother at eight years
old
um would say would you watch these
movies with me because my my dad
wouldn't so we'd watch motel hell and
all these things and so i'm always like
i got a security system i got dogs i got
a
bat next to my bed i got every you know
i look under my bed
it's it's my mom's fault were you always
in the heart how did you get into that
what was it well i remember when uh
when i uh woke up when my parents went
to the movies
and they went and saw the omens this is
probably like 1976
so i was five and my mom was looking
through my hair
yeah she didn't she found a couple of
fives but there was no
but um so that might have but i remember
like like i was always kind of really
obsessed that i go to the library at my
school
and take out any book about horror
movies uh about
greek mythology um hammer films whatever
they had in there in the horror section
and so there was no this is pre-vcr
so there every saturday night there'd be
some horror movies on it late night it
just kind of was um
what they would have in winnipeg so my
mom would let me watch it but i would
have to go to bed at 10 30
uh at night and then wake up at midnight
an hour and a half
later she wouldn't let me sleep the
whole way through but if i could if i
could get up at midnight i was allowed
to go downstairs and watch
horror movies so that's kind of how i
got into it
you see all those old school like i said
hammer films and the
universal films and and all that sort of
stuff and then just kind of went from
there
i just was always attracted to it and
watched you know the 80s was kind of the
advent of
of movies stores and movie rental stores
so you could go to the horror section
and just
choose whatever you wanted and we
watched them all like [ __ ] all of
them yeah you know what obsessed
my buddies we all have a zoom night
horror night every week
so we you know with the things so we're
all you know usually they come over but
obviously you know what people are
spread out and everything so
we zoom it and we said you know let's
watch the whole friday the 13th all all
ten and i was like [ __ ] i i don't to do
that there's a terrible problem i don't
even remember i remember
so we started watching they were kind of
fun in the beginning and then i remember
why they started getting bad a they
never showed the kills as much
you see somebody's head turned but in
the beginning you saw like oh wow the
axe or the you had tom savini doing the
makeup and
it was just so cool and they spent so
much time on it and maybe they cut a lot
of [ __ ]
uh in the later ones and then also and
it may sound chauvinistic but like
i miss seeing boobies yeah and like
even there was a dong in there for
anyone's taste but like a dong some
boobs some
some gross stuff it's just like come on
let's have fun and now it's like oh my
god i barely saw a boob
started they started losing it at six
like four and five are actually really
good
because i just did the same thing i
watched this documentary called return
to crystal lake yeah i'm watching it now
i'm only on episode five
or in the the fifth yeah because it's
like it's like five hours
i'm watching it dude yeah so i would
watch half an hour a day and you start
hearing why like they started cutting
down
uh the cracking down on them for the for
the violence and all that sort of stuff
and
cracking down them for the sex but and
then it just started getting
more and more ridiculous with you know
jason goes to space and all this stuff
but
they have to do friday the 13th part 13.
they have to
they have to do it and then just do that
one and
maybe do like what they did with
halloween where where you know
three through eleven didn't happen and
this takes place right after two
or something along those lines but um i
would really like to see
one more but done really well like like
they've done with the halloween movies
yeah i would like to say you got to do
if it's called friday the 13th you got
to have the 13th installment
i think they went through a lawsuit and
there's a whole bunch of [ __ ] going on
so
yeah exactly so that's what's going on
you'll hear all about the documentary
with sean cunningham
there's another producer involved and it
just kind of gets steve miner probably
yeah exactly he directed uh some
smallville episodes he was a really nice
guy but you don't see him in the
documentary wonder why
yeah yeah exactly exactly all right here
we go [ __ ] talking with rosenbaum or
[ __ ] talking with chris jericho uh this
is fast so
throw them away watch lisa h what's your
favorite wrestling move whether one of
yours or someone else's
uh i love the judas effect which is mine
and i always loved the
rock bottom lucas sam as a lifelong
horror fan i saw that you got to work
in search of darkness part 2 as you
talked about how did you get involved
with the project
they asked me because they know i'm a
really big horror movie fan and uh
they were looking for somebody to kind
of be the figurehead of it and that was
me lee mp
you kind of answered this but you've
been a wrestler had a band different
television shows acted all this stuff
producer which one do you enjoy the very
most
i like when people ask for that because
they say if you only had to choose one
the thing is i don't have to choose one
because i do them both
and they're both amazing in different
ways um
wrestling's i've done it longer i've
been to the high
the highest of heights but my band also
has five
top 30 singles now so we're doing pretty
good in that aspect as well so they're
both just a blast to be involved with
fozzie check them out mark a jericho you
made a career as an entertainment
wrestler actor musician dancer game host
is there any avenue left you haven't
explored that you'd love to try
um i'm sure something will come up i'd
like to do more acting that's always fun
for me
um acting outside of the acting that i
do on on aw every week
so um hopefully maybe some more of that
probably dana asks how do you feel about
the older wrestlers that had so much
success early on in the careers
which we talked about a little bit and
now have nothing but medical problems
and no help from the companies that made
them money
yeah that's the drag that bothers me
when guys you know can't even afford
uh you know to to go get a check
up or whatever it may be there's that i
think there's there should be some kind
of more of a pension type thing but
wrestling's never been that way there's
no union either which is very strange
but it's just the way it is is there a
link or something somebody can go to or
something that helps wrestlers who are
retired or athletes
most times they'll put up gofundme pages
so if you guys are wrestling fans always
keep an eye on social media and you'll
see
somebody needs you know some kind of a
medical uh
issue needs to be fixed or something
simple like the guy
needs a a new motor for his car or
whatever just a lot of stuff like that
that those guys like you mentioned
that were at the highest of heights and
then when it was over they had nothing
left so
um i always try and keep an eye and try
and help out when i can
last question rozzy name something in
your life that you have done that makes
you
proud i think just the biggest thing for
me is the fact that i was able to travel
the world
doing what i always wanted to do you
know it's the old the old saying if if
you
do something that you love you'll never
work a day in your life and obviously
it's a lot of work and it's a lot of
sacrifice and a lot of
you know blood sweat and tears and beers
but
i wouldn't want to do anything else and
i'll be 75 years old sitting in the back
of a starbucks busking if i have to
because i'm an entertainer i got to be
in show miss baby
well listen man i can't wait to maybe
get on the ice with you someday again
i can't wait to come on on your podcast
and yeah sir
and where can they find the podcast just
everywhere man it's called talk is
jericho and it's
it's uh pretty pretty popular so it's
you know itunes spotify apple podcast
all that sort of stuff so he's having a
good time with it it's fun
any movies or anything else coming out i
just did terrifier 2 which if you're a
horror movie fan
be terrified yeah there you go art the
clown crazy
and i did another with kevin smith
called kilroy was here which is a horror
anthology
that i think he's still looking for a
place to get the distribution
which i'm sure will be soon during a
pandemic a finished
done kevin smith movie should be a
no-brainer
inspired but inspired by sticks kilroy
my my team was called domo arigato mr
roboto maybe
yeah maybe dude this has been a real
pleasure man i love talking to you
yeah thanks for reaching out and we'll
do something on my show next we'll find
a topic and delve into it
i can't wait man thanks for allowing me
to be inside of you young man thank you
brother it
all right see you bye take care me too
he's these wrestlers are the kind of
guys ryan that i just
you know i don't want to be in underwear
with them
because you know i their their bodies
are a lot better than mine i would look
like
string beans oh yeah string bean salad
uh i would get destroyed and uh it
scares me it's like wow these guys i
mean they've been doing it their whole
lives i've interviewed dave bautista and
um you know and now jericho and uh it's
pretty fascinating um
batista is trying to get paige on the
podcast for me that'd be cool
and uh somebody else as well so i'm
gonna have to hammer him on that
but thanks chris jericho it was really
enlightening and fun and guys if you if
you came here for chris jericho and
you're still somehow listening you know
like i said
subscribe listen to the podcast support
it write in hello at inside of you
podcast no
hello at insideyoupodcast.com i do read
the messages i don't always send
messages back because i wouldn't leave
the house
and i'd be online all day and that would
be really sad
but i do read your messages and i thank
you um again the handles ryan for ins
uh the podcast uh they are at
insideviewpot on twitter inside of you
podcast
on instagram and facebook youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
that's right
if you want any cool merch go to the
inside of you online store
tons of great stuff tumblers and
autographs and all lex luthor pictures
and sorority boys
i figured you know if people are selling
my [ __ ] online and making money
why shouldn't i at least sell them so
they know they're coming from me
and sell them cheaper than what these
[ __ ] are some by the way you're not
[ __ ] i
i don't get mad at that i'm like do what
you want if you want me to sign an
autograph and you want to go ahead and
sell it for 300
to 3 cents you go do that
because hey everybody has to make a
living but i figure you know at least
you know it's coming from me
it's not as exp it's not expensive it's
not like these other guys so
that's why i do it there'll be some
really cool extra merch coming out too
thanks chris jericho uh ryan we had for
new year's eve what did we do tell
everybody
oh we did bingo over zoom mm-hmm well
bingo i won uh
20 bucks and you won twice which i think
is some [ __ ] well ryan i knew you'd
bring that up
and um i specifically said in the
beginning i am not doing my cards
joe who is virtually out there joe
who's you know joe doesn't cheat old
spina he doesn't cheat he does not he's
exhausted very seriously
and i said i don't even know my card is
i don't know allison sent the cards out
and everyone's like joe how am i doing
you're like oh you're four away and then
bingo
i'm like rosenbaum you got a bingo i'm
like i want 150 bucks
did you did you least kick joe some some
of that 150 bucks
cash i take care of joe all right you
know it's
it's not the way you want to go out on a
but it's it's fitting
and um we were together virtually
and next year we're going to make up for
lost time in fact i'm going to throw
besides
hopefully throwing my summer camp next
year i am going to as you know
camp rosie which i know you'll attend um
and by the way my patrons will get first
dibs on tickets i think it'll probably
sell out but who knows
it's gonna be like a real camp for two
days besides the camp
i want to do um a party that my friend
lally came up with he's called it's
called
the holidays party all the holidays you
missed from 2020 with your friends
you have one big blowout and that's what
i'm gonna do
all a days rose and bombs holidays party
that'll be fun and i can't wait to have
a patron party because i told them one
day when the world's better
we'll figure out a way to get everybody
like you know i'll rent out a place in
l.a or we'll go to a park and we'll
karaoke or some [ __ ] and get some brews
uh here's the patriots who make this
show very possible along with you
listening and
subscribing and all that jazz and um
thank you for everybody
everybody for listening uh again chris
jericho ryan my engineer editor and
bryce my producer
here we go nancy d leah s tricia f
sarah v lisa yukiko jill e brian h
lauren g
nico robin s jerry w emily robert i i'm
gonna hammer you ryan get ready
okay uh jason w stephen j kristen
okay amelia o allison l jess
j lucas m raj c
joshua d emily f
s [ __ ] i think there might be an emily
f2 but wow dude
that was incredible cjp
samantha m jennifer p
now and and jennifer jackie p stacy l
carly h jennifer s janelle b carrie b
tabitha 272 not to be confused ashley
ryan kimberly e crystal h mike e marissa
and
jack slater ramirez beth b santiago m
sarah f chad w
leanne p roshan ray a maya p
maddie s tiffany i kendrick f we're
almost done ashley e
margie m hi marge shannon d
matt w belinda n kevin v james r chris h
anusha w
osborne ellis bjorn h yes gaby m amy c
dave h samantha s spider-man chase
sheila
g ray h alyssa c jacob h tap of the t
miesha h deb a tom and natalie six two
two not to be confused with six two
three alley b
suzanne b s katie f daniela v
lilliana a joseph c michelle k maddie
waggs
marcus w hannaby michael s last five
luke h
john s rob d andrew t christy
s thanks to all the new patrons i
messaged all of you after you joined
patreon.com
inside of you uh this has been a great
episode i look forward to the next one
it's going to be even better next week
you do not want to miss
tom welling my cohort my partner in
crime is back clark kent from smallville
uh you've seen him in lucifer if you've
made it this far in the episode
uh you better come next week because
it's gonna get pretty
noisy um thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you
all of you ryan on a wave
see you guys thanks love you